can you throw comedy punch yeah all the  time okay would you give them that you  have no job pretty he's up for this you  know how hard you have to punch him talk  so you're asking me to pan no not really  an expensive Hollywood no don't break  our Hollywood star breaking then you  mean punch him like a punch Jennifer  yeah yeah okay well then you have to  come and stand over here okay do you  know know you're doing this and it's  you're gonna feel the wind okay  pass your face okay and I just heard you  say that sly is mischievous yes I'm not  mischievous okay so you go straight to  the point  I'm a killer okay this doesn't work I'd  bite your knees don't anticipate okay  I'm kind of come close all right let me  just measure  let me just match them  [Applause]  beautiful daughter  [Music]  you